The First Purge aims to answer a lot of the
major questions that were posed by the original
trilogy.
What kind of economic and social decline might
lead to such a vicious event in the first
place?
What nefarious political underpinnings could
assure that the so-called Experiment would
succeed?
If we thought the New Founding Fathers of
America were depraved before, we hadn't seen
anything yet.
Even so, The First Purge still leaves quite
a few stones unturned.
Here are some of the biggest questions left
unanswered by the film.
Consider yourself warned, there are spoilers
ahead.
Tactical training
Dmitri might lead a life of crime, but he
also has a lot of talents.
He handles himself quite well against the
special ops-type forces on the ground during
the Experiment and has obviously been trained.
Everything from marksmanship to martial arts
to tactical wartime skills for scouring buildings
under siege and planting explosives is in
his skillset.
Where he learned all of these things is something
of a mystery.
There's a vague mention of his combat experience
when he and his team of street soldiers recognize
a mercenary symbol tattooed on their foes'
lifeless bodies, but that's pretty much the
whole story about his ultra-convenient capabilities.
How he manages to be not only as good as this
gaggle of hired guns storming the city, but
good enough to defeat a dozen-plus of them
at once, is simply left to suspension of disbelief.
Experimental controls
The NFFA's spokesman and Experiment "architect"
Dr. Updale are publicly working together on
the first Purge and seem to be on the same
team.
But behind the scenes, their interests differ
significantly.
She's only in it to prove her point that people
need to exercise some lawlessness once a year
to function properly as a society.
But he wants this to work and catch on because
it'll ensure the continued rise of his new
political party.
"This country needs for this to work."
Once he starts sending in hit squads to increase
the body count, she realizes she has no power
over the Purge.
Dr. Updale often describes the Experiment
as an exercise in psychology, but her lack
of actual oversight or physical control undermines
that idea right away.
Is she purposely dense about the true nature
of the night and blindly trusting of the NFFA,
or does she actually believe this is how to
run a controlled behavioral experiment?
In either case, her collegiate credentials
really need to be reviewed.
Lambs to slaughter
The NFFA isn't satisfied until the bloodshed
begins.
They believe the best way to reduce unemployment
and poverty is to let those poor people take
themselves out.
What's not clear, though, is why it takes
graphic violence to make the Experiment a
bankable success where the public is concerned.
The NFFA's spokesman believes that without
a bunch of bloodshed, the organization won't
be able to expand the Purge into a national
event because it won't be attractive to outsiders.
The scenes of cultural unrest seem to show
the exact opposite, though people are marching
for better treatment, not to maim one another
in the streets.
So, wouldn't financial crimes be more attractive
to them?
Why is violence such a selling point to the
public?
You'd think seeing scenes of so much bloodshed
might make people wary of having the Purge
reach their own neighborhoods.
Wouldn't it make more sense to aim for some
of the nation's other low-income areas for
expansion first?
Blood money
A surprising number of people agree to stay
in Staten Island during the Experiment, despite
the possibility that they might fall victim
to whatever untold madness lies ahead.
Part of the reason is that everyone is promised
$5,000 if they stay put, with even more compensation
for those who actually go out and participate
in the ruckus.
But a lot of those people do perish, and it's
not clear what will become of their earnings.
If Purge participants go down, do their loved
ones still get their money?
Do people who don't plan to purge, but end
up doing so, get paid as well?
For that matter, does anyone actually get
paid in the end, or is that all just another
one of the NFFA's lies meant to raise the
body count?
And speaking of the NFFA's trickery, what
happens to all the mercenaries and drones
they called in to raise the stakes in the
first Purge anyway?
Does the public's own thirst for violence
render them unnecessary later on, or is the
party caught cheating their way into a bigger
death toll and forced to do away with them?
Enemy unmasked
Dr. Updale puts a pretty face on the Experiment
and presents the concept as one of societal
self-betterment.
In her mind, if people can live and let die
a little every now and then, they'll be better
citizens overall.
"What have I done?"
The NFFA sees it differently, of course; if
they can push this Purge process far enough,
they can essentially exterminate enough of
the underprivileged population to re-grow
the economy without openly resorting to government-sponsored
genocide.
Naturally, that's not the NFFA's public posturing,
but does the party ever lift the veil on what
they're really trying to accomplish as things
move forward?
It would certainly make sense that they do,
given the racially suggestive diatribe of
the "Polite Leader" in the original Purge
film.
If not, it's also unclear how they might manage
to disguise the Purge's true intention, considering
the fact that the Experiment is televised,
with a lot of the NFFA's hitmen wearing white
supremacist garbs in full view.
America first
America might not be quite so beautiful once
the Purge fully takes hold of society, but
the concept does eventually reduce unemployment
and crime rates by the time the first film
picks up several years in.
In The First Purge, we're treated to a few
news reports about how other First World nations
like Germany start sanctioning the United
States ahead of the initial Experiment and
refer to it as "barbaric."
The question, then, is whether the annual
Purge ever gains steam in other nations as
a result of its economic impact.
Do those who doubt it eventually decide to
participate themselves, or does the United
States continue to remain isolated and ostracized
by its former allies as a result of its newfound
penchant for practical violence?
Perhaps the upcoming Purge TV series will
fill in some of these blanks.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!